we know for sure that the listing will
take place and we know for sure that the
dowel will be the anchor market for it
a secondary exchange is still being
considered and obviously we're in London
and I'll tell you that London is in
contention for that okay London is
contention but so is New York we hear so
as maybe Hong Kong as well so it's it's
a competition isn't it it's not a matter
of a competition but but I think what
we're trying to do is optimize for the
kingdom and we continue to look at the
options this is this decision is way too
important for us to take lightly we will
all know together I mean the decision as
soon as we make it we will announce
practice obviously the big political
issue that we're discussing here in the
UK at the moment and a lot of people are
wondering whether this is making the UK
a less attractive place to invest or a
more attractive place to invest do you
do you have an opinion about what brexit
has done for for how the UK looks as a
prospect you know I think that's
obviously a hot issue here in the UK and
it's a political issue so I want to
tread carefully but as far as I see it
the UK will be less constrained they
will be looking at the world
independently and they will be able to
strike their own deals whether it's
trade cross investment tax treaties so I
see it as a positive from a kingdom
perspective that we could find areas
where we're complementary find areas
with fully aligned and supportive so I
think we can still trade with Europe
independent of the UK but I think the UK
will be more free and depending on how
the UK negotiates with au and with other
partners like us it could indeed be
hugely net positive but time will tell
and with were open to do business with
the UK as well as were they you were
very supportive Leia